die fußball bundesliga in zeiten eines
krieges in europa in allen
bundesliga-stadien gedenkminuten und
unterstützung für die ukraine auch in
frankfurt bei 1 kapitän robert
lewandowski trägt die ukrainische
schlage sogar am partner die eintracht
wirft sich mit allem rein um den
rückstand gegen den rekordmeister
abzuwenden eine aktion entscheidet
dieses spiel der pass von kimmig auf den
vor vier minuten erst eingewechselten
lieber äußern der joker mit dem tor des
abends für die bayern ein wichtiger 1
0-arbeitssieg auf dem weg zum titel die
eintracht hat alle vier heimspiele in
der rückrunde von
marco rose und der bvb unter der woche
mit dem enttäuschenden europa-league-aus
in der liga braucht man weiter punkte um
die bayern nicht aus den augen zu
verlieren in augsburg hat dortmund mehr
vom spiel und belohnt sich in der 35
minute mit dem 1 0 durch tor ghana sah
der sololauf des belgiers findet den weg
ins tor der des niederländers daniel
malen im zweiten durchgang nur den
außenpfosten
doch danach verwaltet der bvb nur noch
seine führung und wird in der 78 minute
dafür bestraft der fca belohnt sich für
seinen willen mit dem 1 1 durch den
eingewechselten saremba sie sichert sich
einen wichtigen punkt im kampf um den
klassenerhalt für dortmund nicht der
gewünschte sieg und die erhoffte
reaktion
rb leipzig das beste team der rückrunde
doch in bohrung geht lange zeit gar
nichts domenico tedesco reagiert
dreifache offensiv wechsel in der 58
minute silber und einkommen bochum der
führung näher zweimal mit alu pech
leipzig mit spielglück
christoph janker acht minuten vor dem
ende doch noch mit dem treffer der
franzose trifft im vierten bundesliga
spiel in folge diskus wechsel bringen
den glücklichen 1 0 sieg ärgerlich aus
sicht der bochumer da möchte man am
liebsten aber überlegt es sich dann doch
noch mal anders
ohne seinen verletzten top-torschützen
patrick schick geht es für bayer
leverkusen in sein heimspiel gegen
bielefeld sein vertreter lukas allah mio
erzielt nach einer halben stunde die
führung für bayer ein treffer mit
diskussionsbedarf vorlagengeber paulinho
schießt sich den ball selbst an die hand
weil das unabsichtlich passiert ist es
auch nicht strafbar der treffer wird
gegeben in der 57 spielminute geht muss
er die abi durch alle bielefelder
hindurch zum 2 2
der franzose derzeit in der form seines
lebens erzählt mit dem 13 0 in der 81
spielminute sein siebtes tor in den
vergangenen fünf spielen diaby und
leverkusen an diesem tag zu stark für
bielefeld die ihre punkte für den
klassenerhalt woanders holen müssen
zwei teams weit hinter ihren eigenen
erwartungen zurück im direkten duell
gladbach und wolfsburg
die gäste mit dem besseren beginn winter
neuzugang jonas wind in der sechsten
minute mit seinem zweiten treffer im
neuen trikot
gladbach mal wieder frühem rückstand und
nach 33 minuten sogar das 2 0 der ex
kölner sebastian bono provoziert mit
seinem jubel die gladbacher auf den
rängen und dem rad doch die borussia
zeigte moral zwei minuten vor der pause
machte rahmen mit dem wichtigen
anschlusstreffer
gladbach schöpft wieder hoffnung der
wolfsburger lacroix in der 70 minute mit
übertriebenen hand einsatz und
unerlaubten handspiel rot für den
franzosen schon der dritte platzverweis
in dieser saison
zehn wolfsburger können dem gladbacher
druck in der 82 minute nicht mehr
standhalten der eingewechselte im polo
mit dem 2 2 ausgleich
matthias kind da in der ersten minute
der nachspielzeit sogar noch mit dem
vermeintlichen siegtreffer doch patrick
herrmann im vorfeld mit dem offensiv
foul schiedsrichter reichel annulliert
das tor es bleibt beim 2 2 der
befreiungsschlag für eines der beiden
teams fällt aus
mit der unterstützung von rund 5000 fans
ist der vfb stuttgart nach sinsheim zur
tsg hoffenheim gereist der vfb tief im
abstiegskampf seit acht spielen ohne
sieg kann in der 58 minute durch wataru
endo mit 1 0 in führung doch kein
bundesligist punktete nach rückstand so
oft wie die tsg christoph baumgartner in
der 85 minute mit diesem traumtor und
dem ausgleich der österreicher ist es
auch der in der 90 minute das 2 1
erzielt zum sechsten mal in dieser
saison kann die tsg 1 rückstand noch zu
einem sieg drehen für den vfb ein
erneuter rückschlag die abstiegssorgen
werden immer größer
seit dem abgang von max kruse ist union
berlin drei spiele sieht und auch tonis
gelegen gegen die derzeit sehr
formstarken mainzer wird nach sieben
minuten der eiserne tor bann endlich
gebrochen
denn die haargummis treffer wird aber
noch mal überprüft doch der vor zentner
liegende krischer krümmel ist nicht mehr
am ball der treffer zählt
mainz beißt sich amon jona
defensivbollwerk die zähne aus den
nächsten treffer erzielen die unioner
und was für ein tier aldo becker mit dem
2 0 in der 56 spielminute die mainzer
schwächen sich danach selbst dominic orr
mit zwei fouls innerhalb von zwei
minuten die gelb rote karte schon im
hinspiel war er vom platz gestellt
worden
beim hinrunden duell war tara boni mit
einem doppelpack der matchwinner hier
erzählt er als joker das 3 0 in der 75
minute die gäste kommen nur noch zum
ehrentreffer der im winter ausgeliehen
delano buch song mit dem 123 mainz
bleibt auswärts harmlos und riesen
erleichterung bei union über das ende
der kleinen negativserie
marcel ob da in der torhüter hierarchie
bei der hertha eigentlich die nummer 5
kommt in freiburg zu seinem
bundesliga-debüt als keeper vor ihm
krank oder verletzt und es kommt noch
dicker für die härter elfte minute ein
schmeichelhafter elfmeter für freiburg
gächter berührt schorle kaum der video
assistent kreist nicht ein vincenzo
brief verwandelt zum 1
die berliner können ihre zahlreichen
ausgleichs chancen nicht nutzen zwei
eingewechselte freiburger tun dass kevin
schade mit dem 2 0 in der 83 minute und
drei minuten später lukas müller mit dem
freiburg träumt weiter von europa der
größte albtraum für die härter heißt
zweite liga die berliner bleiben 2022
sieglos
in der hinrunde noch chancenlos jetzt
konkurrenzfähig kräuter führt seit fünf
heimspielen ungeschlagen
nach einer viertelstunde der kölner
seilbahn spektakulär mit der hacke an
die latte was wäre das für ein schöner
treffer gewesen
sieben minuten nach dem seitenwechsel
der kölner florian kainz mit der
hereingabe und der fall modelt sich ins
fürther tor der österreicher der
torschütze kein mitspieler mehr dran
doch köln konnte in dieser saison
auswärts noch nie zu null spielen so
auch diesmal nicht sebastian griesbeck
in der 69 minute mit seinem ersten
bundesliga tor und dem ausgleich zum 1 1
ein leistungsgerechtes in
der 24 spieltag in der übersicht
dortmund das einzige team unter den
ersten 7 das nicht gewinnen kann bayern
und leipzig mit knappen arbeitslosen und
freiburg mit recht deutlichen heimsiegen
die tabelle die bayern jetzt acht punkte
vor dem bvb leverkusen und leipzig auf
den champions league freiburg und
hoffenheim auf den europa league plätzen
kein team aus der unteren tabellenhälfte
konnte an diesem spieltag gewinnen
augsburg zieht mit dem punkt gegen
dortmund an der heerdter vorbei die nun
auf dem relegationsplatz steht
[Musik]